ese ya el segundo lunes consecutivo de
masivas hace de movilizaciones en las
inmediaciones de la que neces del
parlamento israelí también en otros
puntos de Israel que se suman también a
las ya habituales de cada sábado
iniciadas desde inicios de este año está
claro que los manifestantes están
molestos principalmente porque
consideran que esta reforma atenta
contra la independencia del poder
judicial y ellos dicen también contra la
democracia y en particular cuestionan al
Primer Ministro de Benjamín netañahu
porque él está haciendo investigado por
corrupción y consideran que impulsa esta
reforma para beneficiarse nada de esto
frena los planes del gobierno porque
sigue adelante con su trámite
parlamentario hoy bien decía se espera
la primera de las tres lecturas
necesarias de dos de las leyes de este
paquete una es la que otorga la mayoría
al gobierno en la en el panel que elige
a los jueces no solo de la Corte Suprema
sino de todo del resto del sistema
judicial y también la segunda restringe
la capacidad de revisión de la Corte
Suprema en las llamadas leyes básicas
que son la A falta de constitución en
Israel las leyes principales y que en
parte defienden a las minorías en este
territorio de ahí que si estas leyes
avanzan la ventana de diálogo comience a
cerrarse mucho más la oposición supedita
el diálogo a que estas leyes este el
tratamiento parlamentario se paralice
algo a lo que el gobierno no está
dispuesto a acceder y el centrista Benny
gangs por ejemplo uno de los líderes de
la oposición dijo que si se aprueba esta
primera lectura de estas primeras dos
leyes no entrará en ningún tipo de
diálogo con el gobierno de neta